protesting is now a crime in 2023 the
anti-monarchists were held for many
hours suspected of a plot to disrupt the
coronation by locking onto buildings or
each other
in their van police found suspicious
luggage straps and locks for carrying
heavy placards said the protesters their
leader Graham Smith said months of
liaising with police on the day counted
for nothing
immediately we were surrounded by large
numbers of tactical support group
officers who were not in remotely
friendly or helpful mindset we never had
any intention of doing anything which
even came close to Falling outside of
the law and the claim that they had
intelligence could not possibly be true
either they are being dishonest or they
are making a very serious error
come on
the MP session was interrupted briefly
perhaps to little surprise by a
protester to be clear they would just
stop oil protesters who tried to
undermine the activities of this
committee with our Witnesses today
[Music]
three days before the coronation
Parliament had given police tough new
powers to search and arrest to prevent
public protests turning into disruption
had the police overreacted I felt under
no pressure politically I felt pressure
to deliver a safe and secure operation
but that was because of the fact it was
a once in a lifetime event for so many
people and we are continually balancing
the rights of those who seek to protest
with those who are impacted by it
the officer said police action had to be
seen in context late intelligence had
warned of paint sprayers Invaders along
the Route and rape alarms to scare
horses
a volunteer handing out rape alarms was
arrested with colleagues we did the best
that we could to try and explain who we
were
I'm a bit speechless
teaching her that account
of what happened to you your colleagues
the day 52 protesters were arrested
there was tension and rival chanting but
no disruption to the coronation because
we're low in lowering the threshold for
what isn't allowed in our society
um to disruptive it's going to lead to
lots more police involvement it's going
to be a lot more encounters with the
police but that is undoubtedly in my
view going to radicalize groups of
protesters
the evidence gathered by MPS is expected
to be considered in their report this
summer on policing priorities Marty
brunt Sky News Westminster